it's all happening we're making a new
beginning hey everybody it's Charlie
this is gonna be my Walking Dead Season
9 episode 1 video obviously we got to
talk about how they changed things
trying to fix all the complaints from
the past couple of seasons there's a
brand new showrunner so just careful for
spoilers if you have not seen the
episode yet if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I'll talk about schedule and
future Walking Dead videos at the end of
this because they are changing a lot of
things this season Andrew Lincoln and
lauren cohan have already revealed that
this is gonna be their last season as
main cast members not that they'd never
come back but I'll address that at the
end of the video too because obviously
it's a very big deal but a top 10 WTF
and comic book Easter eggs starting with
number 10 how things have changed with
the time jump so if it wasn't clear
there was a bit of a time jump but not
an extreme jump because Glen's baby has
been born Maggie is no longer pregnant
there were a lot of questions about that
but they open with a montage of going
around all the different groups just
letting you know that they're all kind
of working together but obviously things
sort of slide downhill through the
course of the episode like even though
they're attempting to work together not
everybody is really happy with the
situation
Rick's whole thing the first half of the
season or at least at the start they're
gonna attempt to look to the past to
help them with the present meaning
they're going all Westworld going with
old school technology and farming
methods to help them feed themselves and
get around although I would say Eugene's
invention of the corn fuel is actually
probably one of the most useful things
that they have besides just growing food
number 9 big change the new title
sequence also denoting the showrunner
change if you don't know who Angela Kang
is she's been with the show since the
beginning she's the new showrunner Scott
Gimple has transitioned to more of an
overarching creative role in helping
them with all their spin-offs in the
movies they're trying to develop yes
there are Walking Dead movies that
they're trying to make who knows if any
of those will actually make it to the
screen is this all part of AMC's plan to
exploit the Walking Dead property as
much as possible they attend more
spin-offs all kinds of stuff you've
probably been hearing about it the last
couple of months number eight Rick rides
into the Capitol with all the other main
characters really nice mirror of the
pilot episode when you see him riding
into Atlanta on horseback you get a nice
shot of the Capitol bill
they're really going to the National
Museum of American history to get the
heirloom seeds that's all part of their
big plot but while they're in the
capital they make all these references
to new government restarting democracy
there's all kinds of funny metaphors so
if you're not a big comic book reader
there actually is a new government in
The Walking Dead comics I don't know if
we're gonna see them this season maybe
in a future season because we know we're
getting the whisperers and it feels like
they try to introduce one big group at a
time so if we do whispers next then we
might not meet the Commonwealth the new
government for quite a while number
seven you may have spotted the funny
manifest destiny metaphor when Michonne
was noticing the big trap that they used
for the first big action scene that big
glass floor with all the walkers beneath
it the joke that they're making about
manifest destiny is if you're not
familiar with the concept manifest
destiny is the idea that imperialist
tactics like expansion is sometimes
necessary and inevitable so they're just
making the joke that the walkers
expansion around the world is inevitable
so it's manifest destiny but with a
really sinister twist number six was the
spider pinata Walker you could tell that
they lingered on that shop for a long
time they really wanted to have some fun
with this but it's the month of
Halloween so of course they're gonna do
stuff like that that just happened to be
their special quote-unquote Walker of
the episode five and of the scavengers
explains the heirloom seed plot so they
grab pretty much everything they said to
grab it all we'll take it so they're
trying to grab tools they were trying to
grab all the supplies that they would
need to use the heirloom seeds but while
they're doing this they all kind of
touch around the different groups
Darrell even remembers Merle like he
doesn't admit that he misses him but he
does say there's other people like Beth
for instance that he wishes were with
them now the really good thing I think
that Norman Reedus does with the way he
performs the darrell character isn't
showing a lot of emotion without
actually physically showing a lot of
emotion you can just kind of read what
he's really thinking on his face even if
he's not talking about it we have our
first big action scene when they almost
fall through the floor they almost fed
Ezekiel to the Walker pit they used the
safe to let you know that he and Carol
are officially together and even though
he wants to move forward it was a bit of
a subplot like then this season whether
or not they will make a go of it the way
that Rick and Michonne are making a go
of it number four was them losing the
newb so I kind of
wondered why they gave these new
characters so much of a character arc at
the beginning but it was them just
setting up this payoff that would
eventually culminate in the Gregory
twist at the end of the episode they did
try to get you to care about all these
secondary characters but usually what
they will do is when they have a red
shirt in an episode sometimes they'll
give him a couple lines of dialogue so
that you kind of know who he is like oh
he's that one guy that was talking about
this one thing he had a father that one
of the other guys wanted to apprentice
to they also use that to remind you that
Sadiq is with them he's now the official
main doctor on the show pretty much
number 3 Gregory's insurrection plot he
tries to get the people to turn against
Maggie
uses the dead boy gets the Father drunk
so that he'll attack Maggie without
realizing what he's doing then - before
she resolves that she gets really
hardcore with Rick about how things are
going to change going forward we're not
gonna help out the Savior's anymore
unless we're getting something in return
so she gives him all those demands and
it's really just the show letting you
know that Maggie is super hardcore now
and she's not gonna take any [ __ ] from
anybody this is probably the beginning
of the end of her arc remember I said
that lauren cohan is not gonna be a main
cast member after this season so what
they might do is is use this dark
Maggie's storyline to make her go a
little off the deep end and maybe she
realizes that she needs a break so that
she can leave the show without them
having to kill her character off so I
don't know that they would kill Maggie
at the end of the season because lauren
cohan did imply that she would be coming
back but just not as a main cast member
so just cameos and whatever future
seasons but of course number one she
executes Gregory in the comic book way
circumstances were a little bit
different in the comics she hung him
from a tree he or she just did it in
retaliation for his failed plot to get
rid of her but again the way Maggie ends
that moment is actually really awesome
just because she is so dark and the kids
come walking up wait stop she seems a
little bit sorry that the kids had to
see that but she's just so intense in
that moment that she just brushes right
past it
they play the teaser for the next week's
episode and it's all about rebuilding
the bridge so that might cross the next
couple of episodes like their next big
art because it seems like a really
intense project so I'd be blown away if
they get past that in a single episode
but it's just more drama between the
groups
Rick thinking they need a charter and
everyone being nostalgic for old times
even darryl references their original
group we could have done anything that
group now I'm not so sure the really big
question is is do you think that they
corrected some of the mistakes of them
spinning their wheels in the last two
seasons I think one of the biggest
changes was them trying to show people
accomplishing a goal people being more
mobile you didn't have a bunch of people
just sitting around in the same place
but a lot of that just depends on how
the next couple of episodes go so we'll
see if they can maintain their momentum
but I do think that they lived up to the
title of the episode a new beginning so
very meta in that aspect but just let me
know what you guys thought of it in the
comments below
what'll happen is is just depending on
how everybody feels about the season
I'll do more videos I will at least do
another video when Andrew Lincoln leaves
the show I think his last episode might
wind up being the mid-season finale so
if everybody is really on board for
weekly episodes then I'll do that if not
no worries but obviously there are a
couple big moments that will be
happening this season Andrew Lincoln and
lauren cohan leaving so we'll probably
find out more about that soon but
clicking for my new Game of Thrones
Season 8 direwolves video and click here
to watch Mark Ruffalo attempt to give
away the title to Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome we'll see you guys tonight